18.
IN FOR JON COOPER, THEY TALKED
ABOUT
KEEPING IT INSIDE THE LINE,
MORE PRESSURE, SERGACHEV DOWN
WITH A LITTLE TIP, IT GOES JUST
REALLY GOT CAUGHT THERE, THEY
WERE NOT READY FOR THE RUSH
IT'S A WALK
IS BELLMAWR, UP HIGH, IN THE
ZONE.KEY PLAYER WANTS TO BE
CALLED'S KLINGENBERG TRIES TO S
PAST HIS MAN.
JO
STARS HAVE  SCORED FIRST.FINALL
HEDMAN, PULLINOFF WIN BY ANTHON
REALLY.
HOLD ONTO THE PUCK, ALMOST
STANDING STILL IN THE ZONE.
ACROSS TO
GREAT STOP COMING ACROSS ON
POINT.
BEAUTIFUL
HOCKEY, ON BOTH SIDES.
WHAT IS SAVED BY ANTON
DALLAS WITH A LITTLE PUSHBACK,
ALL AFTER THAT ANTON KHUDOBIN
SAVE
SERGACHEV, A SHOT SAVE AGAIN BY
IS A FREE, HE THOUGHT HE HAD
IT, WRAPAROUND ATTEMPTED UP BY
NIKITA KUCHEROV.SATURDAY NIGHT
THEY ARE STARTING TO GET INTO S
INCOMES ANTHONY SABELLA, O OE D
ZACH BOGOSIAN KNOCKED IT DOWN.
MICHAEL
AT THE END, HE FELT LIKE HE GOT
TRIPPED.
>> HE
ANDRE VASILEVSKIY PLAYS A BACK
ON THEAVE, WITH THE
GOING RIGHT ON THROUGH HIM,
OTHERWISE,